2:19 p.m. which means well well Golden
Ears oh yeah so he's turning 12 on
January 12th which means this is Isaac's
building here and he's also year of the
rat which is 2020 year the rat
so dude this is your good luck year you
ready for this
what are we doing today we are at Disney
World yeah well California right now
every adventure
we're a California Adventure verse I
grew up yeah pretty much
it's been coming here since he was a
baby
we had the annual pass like a few years
in a row so I was coming here all the
time but I was like when he was a baby
like a little toddler and now seeing him
turned 12 and celebrating it here's your
one year away from becoming a teenager
do it already at my second home your
second phone yeah
when'd you have your first phone oh
that's right back we went to Hawaii and
then I jumped into the ocean with my
phone in my cement runs pocket and so
like crap I don't want to pay for it on
the phone we gave him my old phone but
just to use as like yeah pretty pretty
much like a knife line where you just
play games and stuff and it wasn't
connected to any cellular service but
technically that was your first phone so
now
you're second but because I promised him
for his 13th birthday he can finally
join everyone else who is addicted to
this thing you've been very patient
though I appreciate that thank you for
being so patient you're such a good kid
[Music]
[Applause]
today
[Music]
like a lowered his voice for that one
your Jolla teenager you're like okay mom
till you're embarrassing me
you're being so cringe mom did you just
dab on me oh my god
he likes crunchy people
his friend Jesus is this
I'm cringing dude what is this bring my
own ankles try to do that fooling is
such a dad you sir are you
[Music]
happy forensic my little man
I'm gonna go by himself then okay I'm
gonna wait over there we're crapping
this 12-year old style alright peace how
does it feel to play your baby boy go
off on his own thirty feet
like really nervous and like busy
talking to strangers is someone gonna
okay so see him that's like a
five-year-old's in my head say like oh
my baby is they okay but I gotta remind
myself
well now that's you guys they get you
does it ever get you choked up thinking
about him getting older and older and
like yeah
when I think about and he was my baby
like notice I remember you know the day
he was born and so
and realizing how much climate
[Music]
starting now always feel like I need a
try extra hard tonight baby me Marcus
Oneg the baby hemline now some like our
little bro let him grow
[Applause]
oh there it is there's a zoomed-in any
movement you can lose it how was it
alright my big boy yeah was it different
than riding with us or with like other
people they'd just be by yourself which
felt the same - 19 p.m. which means
happy birthday
I was just selling home like I remember
the moment you were born
[Music]
he actually wears the bigger shoe size
than I do now
he's like getting closer and closer to
it
[Applause]
[Music]
and he just feel like perfectly right
here
I think is old enough to be the driving
force of our Disney adventures now he's
been leading the day all day
anything you want yeah I on the energy
to do this Disney stuff for very much
longer been here so many times just
going through the motions now
doing diddly days throughout my life
true I'm not saying that I don't want to
come back I'm just saying I'm just
saying my body feels a little different
these days this is your last year of
being a kid before your age has the word
teen built into every year before before
you're an adult yeah before you're an
adult so in the during this year what
are you gonna accomplish before becoming
a full-blown teenager what do you what
do you hope to do
[Applause]
you can still go to buffets and be like
half-price he doesn't he's not I'm on
that level we got to go to more per face
right now
now you can take medication in pill form
yeah 13 is the big year make sure you
can go into pg-13 movies by yourself oh
we get to watch on the bg-30 my babies
come on it's rated R he's only like 17 I
was gonna happen very soon oh no he's
not no it's not
[Music]
alright baby you've had a full day
California Adventure is your birthday my
favorite part right yeah that one's
always my favorite ride because it feels
like I'm going to therapy like scream
there because I just bring my lungs out
and just feel so good when we walk away
it's like oh you're like
[Music]
you share the same birthday with a lot
of people today rear body eat some
spaghetti / Italian so yes I'd like what
would you like for your birthday dinner
he was like Italian food and we found
calamari and we're gonna celebrate
Drake's : nice getting his drink to
Hallie and Johnny basically closed the
credit construe they really wanted to
write it like for the third or fourth
time or who were about to leave we hear
them testing it out like and then we
don't hear any screams so like all right
schölermann
and then I was just killing time just
for the perfect moment and then we're
sitting down
like it's open yeah we're so happy you
like your birthday wish come true
[Music]
how is it I've never ordered a cream
soda I've never seen anyone order cream
soda the cream soda with actual cream
and actual soda separated it like
layered in glass that we've started it
was really beautiful when I came out but
yeah I think mixed in the later looks
like a glass of milk but that is the
best cream soda I've ever had oh my gosh
[Music]
happy birthday dude
Bieber start singing some song you happy
birthday
dear
[Music]